mathieu plestan bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france ce matin on le
voyait un des manifestations violentes
en australie contre la vaccination
obligatoire et ce sont notamment les
professionnels du bâtiment acquis sont
en colère qu'est ce qu'ils revendiquent
mais ce qu'ils revendiquent tout
simplement c'était plus ou moins un
meilleur délai sur les sons les sur les
vaccinations on leur a donné simplement
quelques jours de deux notifications ce
qui est ce qui est très peu par rapport
au nombre de 25 ya ici en australie
actuellement donc ils protestent ils
protestent contre contre ça et contre ce
le fait que que voilà il n'y a pas eu
forcément de
de douane communication de la part de la
part du gouvernement et de la terre de
toutes les instances de toutes les
instances mathieu les australiens qui
sortent d'un sixième confinement
particulièrement à melbourne dans des
conditions donc très stricte est ce que
ça fait évidemment monter un peu la
tension
ah oui complètement complètement toutes
les tout le monde ici est vraiment à
bout de 2 to say confinement on en est
presque 9e et c'est long c'est très long
il ya plein de personnes qui qui font
des sacrifices qu'il ya plein de
personnes qui se font vacciner qui s'en
fait dax ine mais voilà c'est vrai que
tout le monde et est tabou de cette
situation et ce qui devait arriver ce
qui devait arriver malheureusement est
arrivé puis et puis voilà on voit toutes
ces scènes de violence dans les rues
d'un pays qui est pourtant l'un des plus
longs et plus relax au monde donc ça ça
fait contraste par rapport au mode de
vie qu'on a un qui avait avant ici dans
ce pays est maintenant bel tout le monde
tout le monde on peut plus de ces
compliments et en espère espère être
être re sortir assez rapidement et
certains voient une tentative de
déstabiliser
de groupuscules alors est ce que c est
ce qu on dit là bas en australie est-ce
que ses jt oui
notamment le président de l'union qui
s'était de l'union des syndicats du
bâtiment excusez moi qui s'est exprimé
ce matin et qui a annoncé que certaines
personnes n'étaient pas forcément
des membres de leurs de leurs syndicats
étaient plus des groupuscules d'extrême
droite
c'est difficile à dire difficile à avoir
difficile de faire la différence entre
ces personnes
normal c'est les syndiqués et entre et
entre ces personnes ces groupuscules
d'extrême droite c'est très difficile à
dire mais effectivement il ya eu
apparemment j'ai pas plus d'informations
mais mêlée des groupuscules d'extrême
d'extrême qui est qu'ils sont roque qui
sont qui sont eux qui ont pris part à
ces manifestations
matthieu lahaye les conséquences
économiques après justement toutes ces
fermetures notamment dans le bâtiment
pour la population en général
est ce qu'elle est difficile à supporter
oui alors il ya une perte de 2 milliards
de dollars australiens suite à ces
acides deux semaines de d'arrêt de
travail je parle pour pour le secteur du
bâtiment donc les pertes sont énormes
c'est un secteur qui est vraiment
important ici ici en australie et les
différents les différents
confinement également porté préjudice à
de nombreuses autres secteurs notamment
dans la restauration le tourisme tous
les restaurants sans sont fermés depuis
quasiment à dire 1 en mai mais presque
on a eu quand même quelques périodes de
déconfinement mai mais voilà c'est c'est
difficile à supporter pour pour tout le
monde et en attendent attendent plus de
la part du gouvernement qui vient en
aide à un certaine incertain certains
secteurs parce que ben est forcément
c'est très difficile pour tout le monde
merci beaucoup mathieu plestan d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin sur rtl
france je le rappelle vous êtes
journaliste indépendant en australie